mit seinen rund 210.000 einwohnern hatte
rostock die geringste corona incidents
in deutschland es sind nur 45
wöchentliche neuinfektionen auf 100.000
einwohner
das ist zumindest der stand noch von
vergangenem mittwoch ja was machen die
rostocker besser als der rest in
deutschland das wollen wir wissen
vielleicht können wir auch was lernen
und deshalb sprechen wir mit dem
bürgermeister klaus mack ist schön dass
sie für uns zeit haben mehr masse wie
erklären sie sich denn ihre niedrigen
zahlen was machen sie besser als der
rest deutschlands
naja ich denke es ist ein großer
blumenstrauß an ganz unterschiedliche
sachen was wir sehr sehr streng
maßnahmen einhalten und es ist uns
tatsächlich gelungen von tag eins bis
heute alle kontakte immer
nachzuverfolgen das heißt er über die
ansteckungskette nachvollziehen können
und das ist ganz wichtig dafür gab es
einen halt keine überweisung das heißt
wir unser gesundheitsamt immer permanent
ausgebaut und dafür gesorgt dass die
immer genug leute da waren um die
kontakte halt genau zu prüfen und den
übrigen wir sind nicht bei 45 sondern
heute stand 33,9 also sehr sehr gut und
darüber freuen wir uns das wichtige ist
natürlich nicht wo wir heute stehen
sondern hoffentlich wo wir haben ende
der pandemie stehen und daran dass mir
jeden tag maschinen auch ärmel
hochkrempeln und alles dazu viele fragen
allerdings auf testet überhaupt erst
richtig und testet rostock genauso wie
alle anderen dass es natürlich fragen
sich sehr oft beantworten ja
mathematische sehtest mir genau so
klingen wie alle anderen ob wir jetzt
die richtigen testen kann ich nicht
sagen aber ich gucke auch oder hochgeht
tagen man kann ja sagen und dafür aber
dass im krankenhaus noch sehr viel platz
hat und vor allen dingen ganz rechts
außen immer in der tabelle eine ganz
wichtige information steht immer wie
viele todesfälle hat man zu verzeichnen
und jahren wir haben insgesamt auf
210.000 einwohner nur elf tote ich
glaube durchschnittlich gestern hatte
deutschland mittlerweile die 50.000 der
marke gerundet dann hätten wir jetzt 125
zu mathematisch haben können also man
kann davon ausgehen dass wieder
ordentlich testen so gut auf unsere
bürgerin
würde auch passen und vor allen dingen
und das ist das worauf nicht als bürger
weiß natürlich besonders schön sind
meine bürgerinnen und bürger verstehen
ist auch sich untereinander aufzupassen
also ich bin sehr froh darüber dass die
überwiegende menge an die rostockerinnen
und rostocker war echt sehr vorbildlich
unterwegs sind
das hat sich tatsächlich sehr gut an
eine frage noch vieh kümmern sie sich um
die älteren haben sie dort auch einen
besonderen schutz
ja also auch dort mit getestet jeder
rein wirft ja auch mitarbeiter haben
seit längerem ein sehr strenges test
konzept jetzt hatte ich zum letzten mal
gehört dass der ein oder andere mal
gesagt hat so ein gast sie könnte auch
so ein gentest und das hat mich sehr
sehr verärgert man hat so gesagt wir
haben ja niedrige zahlen nichts
passieren und genau das ist das worauf
wir aufpassen wollen ich erzähle dann
immer gerne die geschichte vom löwen
also man stelle sich vor in der die
würde ich berichten ein löwe sind laufen
sind innenstadt kaum jemand übel
ausgehen
und wenn jemand dann lügen mit zum
einkaufen bringen würde im supermarkt
würde jeder abstand halten
und ich glaube dass niemand an löwen mit
in einem pflege oder altenheim mit
reinbringen würde und du wirst uns
einfach vor augen halten dass jeden tag
dieser löwe 1000 menschen von
deutschlands straßen geholt was es geht
jetzt wirklich dass wir den löwen
gezähmt bekommen dass wir darauf
aufpassen und deswegen immer die motive
schon man die leute
wir müssen jeden tag ärmel hoch
aufpassen auch verdammt aufpassen
weiterhin so gut und dann hoffe ich
darauf dass fonds franken blieb mit coco
nach hinten kann das haben sie uns jetzt
auf jeden fall sehr schön verbildlicht
und wir drücken ihnen auch weiterhin die
daumen dass die zahlen so niedrig
bleiben bei ihnen rostock vielen dank an
sie mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei der schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren